Criticize uh.
The territorial majority,
in particular on its action
not to have,
uh
curb uh.
This immigration policy,
not having to exercise the controls,
but how 1 region
uh.
As or any other can do,
you misunderstand our criticism.
We do not blame him,
we do not reproach him for not having exercised
exemptions,
recommendations,
rather the means they do not have,
we agree.
On the other hand,
on the other hand,
we reproach the territorial majority
and 1 number of sectors
dominant nationalism that are inherited
of the 70s,
to play the game
and to enter into pacts and alliances with sectors
of the French political game that
encourages immigration very clearly.
I think
especially to the alliances continue with the glasses,
but more particularly
sponsorships,
sponsorships of Jean-Luc Mélenchon by 6 members
of the territorial majority at the request of the
Chairman of the Executive
during the celebrations
with the arrival of immigrants,
it is 1 political marker
essential,
the gold you support
forces that support a policy
Massive immigration.
Well,
you are necessarily an accountant
the results of this policy,
it seems logical to me.
And concerning indeed
the rapprochement with the green
which is apparently no longer relevant,
I dare to believe the Europeans.
In any case,
I dare to believe that the action of paladine
and uh.
Uh.
I would say the spacing of the hornet window,
that our action to commit suicide
uh. It's not for nothing.